في بدايه السنه كنا تناولنا خبر انه شركه
دونات باي بتخطط على شان انها تستخدم رابط
محامي داخل قاعه المحكمه لاول مره هذه
الروبوت بقدم منشوره قانونيه للمدعي عليه
وبساعده طيب قامت الدنيا وما قعدت عن
الموضوع لدرجه انه مدير الشركه تعرض
لتهديدات من نقابه المحاميين والعقوبه
السجن وقال انه اجلت الموضوع طيب المفاجاه
اليوم ان الروبوت المحامي هذا اللي بتكلم
عنه بيواجه هو نفسه دعوه قضائيه رفعها
علاء احد العملاء اللي استعانوا فيه فاللي
صار انه الرجل استعان بخدمات شركه دونات
باي لكتابه وثائق قانونيه مختلفه لكن
الوثائق ما عجبته وكانت دون المستوى
المطلوب ووقت تعرف انه اللي كتب المستندات
هو المحامي الروبوت
راح لجا لمكتب محاماه ورفع دعوه الشركه
صاحبه المحامي الروبوتو فحوى الدعوه انه
هذا الروبوت المحامي بيمارس مهنه المحاماه
من دون ترخيص
مدير الشركه تبع مسكت لسه قال انه راح
يدافعوا عن نفسهم وكنوع من التحدي كمان
كتب في تغريده انه احتمال يستخدم الروبه
المحامي نفسه في هذه القضيه